Jing Wang: So back to NGO 2.0
because we wanted to introduce
2.0 thinking and practice to
NGOs. Therefore, we started off
with a social media literacy
training.
We teach grassroots NGOs and
western and central provinces of
China to learn how to use social
media to engage in participatory
thinking, launch interactive
advocacy campaigns, increase the
transparency of NGO operation,
design online crowdfunding
projects and learn Human
Centered Design to create
solutions to the problems that
NGOs are tackling.
To date, we have trained
approximately 2200 NGOs. And
this is a part of our
curriculum. We also created
other programs, for example, we
developed a web 2.0 toolbox for
NGOs. We also build a
crowdsource philanthropy map,
over which more than 27,000 NGOs
have registered their project
data and organization data. We
also run civic hackathons in
collaboration with transnational
IT companies, domestic Chinese,
IT companies, software developer
and maker communities and
universities, especially
departments of computer science
and design. in universities, we
have worked with Ching Hua
University, and the University
of Science and Technology of
China and senior sign University
etc.
Non confrontational activism is
a thematic thread running
through my new book, the other
digital China. Now, during my 10
year long experience of running
NGO 2.0, I encountered a variety
of puzzled responses from my
colleagues and friends in the
US, they ask, how could a
foreign NGO specializing ICT
activism survive at all in such
an adverse environment like
China?
This question, however, is a
false question. Because, first
of all, and to 2.0 is not an
international NGO. From day one,
I made sure that we set it up as
a local Chinese NGO operated by
a largely indigenous Chinese
team. We now have seven full
time employees in China. So the
challenges at the core of our
operation are not much different
from those faced by the other
grassroots NGOs in China. So we
should so the question we should
ask instead is, how have the
Chinese NGOs fared through the
success of reigns of an
authoritarian regime? Well, to
farewell in China requires a
different mindset and a
different strategy, which is
learning the art of restraint
and following the centuries old
cultural logic of finding the
middle ground whereby emissions
however difficult will get
accomplished. This for the
Chinese activists, this means
producing social good without
throwing a street revolution, or
confronting the state openly and
aggressively.
During the past 10 years, I was
exposed bit by a bit to a
gradually unfolding captivating
picture of social media activism
in China, in which multiple
players from diverse sectors are
leveraging the network effect of
2.0 to equate incremental change
in China. And this book is
devoted to the ICT practices
emerging from China's social
sector caught at a specific,
particular historical moment,
thanks partly to the arrival of
2.0 technology, and cyber
utopianism, and partly to the
Communist Party's alleged
commitment to policies and
energizing the weak social
sector. Now with this book, I
was trying to answer to ask the
question, what is the ecosystem
of social media activism looking
like in China today in the old
media environment of the major
civic actors for NGOs, but since
2009, after social media had
gone mainstream in China, Mike
did this old ecosystem has
changed. Because microblogging
brought in four new groups of
social actors, they are the free
agents, corporate sector,
software, developer communities
and maker labs and the
university sector, and NGO 2.0
designed projects that involve
participants from all those
sectors. I should also note that
the great majority of social
actors we collaborate with are
Chinese millennials and members
of the generation seeing all
those social actors share a
commitment to making incremental
change rather than throwing a
street revolution.
And together,
those actors from diverse
sectors are building an
invisible coalition to bring
incremental change to Chinese
society in spite of censorship.
If you want me to choose a
single sentence to describe this
book, it would be this is a book
about the gray zones in China,
integrate zones Chinese
activists practice non
contentious social actions. So
let's take a deeper dive into
this keyword, non
confrontational activism and and
ask what kind of politics it
implies. And how does the
concept and practice of non
confrontational ism challenged
the mainstream Western liberal
thinking about activism? Chinese
social actors I named above
don't fit squarely into the
profile of activists prescribed
in the western liberal
tradition, because Chinese
changemakers are walking around
obstacles rather than breaking
through them. And they navigate
tactfully between what is lawful
and what is illegitimate. We're
all familiar with a Western
paradigm that tend to equate
action with resistance and
social change with street
revolutions. And I think it is
time that non confrontational
activism is conceptualized,
fully documented with case
studies so that we can put on
the front burner, a very
important question, which is the
agency of activists operating in
authoritarian countries. Now
generally speaking, activists
practicing non confrontational
ism are anonymous because their
actions purposefully attract no
attention. They stay on the
margins of history, and they
remain peripheral to academic
discussions about social
actions, even though it prevails
in all autocratic societies,
where activists resort to other
means of serving social good,
then openly rebelling and openly
critiquing. In my book, I
incorporated a chapter on the
critical literature revolving
around the concept of practice
of non confrontational this.
Here, I want to single out one
such book James C. Scott's
Weapons of the Week: Everyday
Forms of Personal Resistance.
James guard introduced the
concept of invisible agents and
their quiet and piecemeal
tactics. He also gave credit to
what he called the practice of
calculated conformity.
He did well, James Scott's
peasants typically avoid a
direct and dramatic
confrontation with the
authorities. But instead of
condemning the peasant silence,
as complicitous, or devoid of
politics, Scott locates the
sights of peasant action in
micro and conspicuous everyday
forms of food tracking, false
compliance, feigned ignorance
and so on. And this book
represents a significant
milestone in valorizing the
powerless as political agents.
Now when we turn to a country
like China or other illiberal
societies, where open resistance
is an exception rather than the
norm. We, as researchers are
called upon to go beyond the
dichotomous mode of thinking to
solve a puzzle. The puzzle is
why are they exploited in those
countries accept their situation
as a normal, or even as a
justifiable part of social
order? Are Chinese people
fatalistic, complicitous or
paralyzed by fear and cowardice?
So this question has been
sitting on a lot of people's
mind. Surely, if the Chinese
government could hire as many as
2 million people to insert
deceptive writings into social
media posts, shouldn't we have
good reasons to believe that
Chinese censorship has
penetrated every corner of that
society, and that the censors
have manipulated the public
opinions effortlessly? Well,
that is the conventional reading
of the muted consensus of
Chinese people over maintaining
the status quo. And that
formulation relegates the entire
population of China into the
category of the brainwashed. In
reality, though, we know that
Chinese people have more choices
than being brainwashed and
becoming martyrs. So what is
missing? In the scholarly
research on China is the massive
middle ground in which
conformity is often a self
conscious strategy, and that it
might be possible to think of a
continuum of situations ranging
from the free dialogue, what
carbon was called ideal speech
situation, or the public sphere,
all the way to the concentration
camp. So what is understudied in
the China field is that
continuum of situations, or the
middle ground, or the gray
zones, in which the Chinese
activists navigate day in and
day out quite successfully. As
we all knew that the favorite
topic, the hottest topic for
digital China's scholars in the
West is Chinese censorship, with
this book and taking a different
path. If we want to understand
the real everyday China, it is
imperative we go beyond the
simple dichotomy of white and
black and turn our gaze toward
the gray. So all this may sound
a bit abstract. What did I mean
when I say Chinese activists
operate in the gray zones? So
let's take NGOs for example, and
illustrate how NGOs in China
function in a tightly controlled
social space? Or we could ask a
slightly different question.
What is the relationship between
Chinese NGOs and Chinese state?
The shorthand answer to that
question is NGOs in China are
compelled obliged to learn how
to navigate within the state
apparatus. Now, if you want me
to choose three adjectives to
describe Chinese NGOs, they
would be semi official semi
popular semi autonomous, semi
official refer to the NGOs
navigating within the state
structure, somehow popular
refers to the self
identification of grassroots
NGOs. Semi autonomy is the
concept I will explain later.
There is a Chinese saying, don't
start, hey, if you're going to
learn quite a few Chinese
sayings tonight, the most
invisible place is the spot
right underneath the light this
the spot the spot, which means
no place is safer than the place
of danger. In other words, under
the surveillance of the party
state, it is easier to carve out
breathing spaces within the
state structure within the plant
space, then create an outside.
So here, hence the Chinese
paradox. The closer the
relationship of NGO is to the
Chinese state, the more
autonomous,
the more autonomous, it would
become. Now, this may still
sound abstract, so let me share
with you an anecdote.
In the late 1990s, I started a
collaborative research project
with a professor at Peking
University on popular media and
popular culture in China. We
wanted to hold an international
conference in Beijing. But
finding a safe conference venue
was very difficult because the
word media in the conference
title is politically sensitive
in China. We eventually overcame
the problem by holding our
conference at a state owned and
state run hotel, we were able to
do this because one of our
participants had a personal
relationship with a hotel
manager. So there was no
surveillance, no questions
asked, and the conference went
on very smoothly. So this is a
very good example that
illustrates what I meant by the
safest place is the place of
danger. The most invisible place
is the spot right underneath the
light. So those habitually cling
on to the Western binary
thinking and Western binary
dichotomous paradigms will have
difficulties grasping how
Chinese people navigate in the
seemingly seamless web of
political control. Now, I want
to emphasize that all Chinese
people, not just Chinese
activists have a half a circle
mindset. They are very good at
finding creative ways of walking
around obstacles. That's the set
of NGOs in a liberal societies
tend to practice non
confrontational activism by
default, and it is imperative
they make change within the
system. I'm going to give you a
quote, to further unbundle this
paradox. This is this quote was
from Anthony sage, he was the
former chief of Ford Foundation
in Beijing. He now teaches at
Harvard's Kennedy School. So he
says Chinese NGOs voluntary
subordination to the existing
state structure should be viewed
not as a measure of expediency
but a strategic move to enhance
the ability to manipulate the
official and semi official
institutions for their own
advantage, which means making
more impact on society and
gaining a louder voice in
Policymaking discussion stand if
they were to remain completely
autonomous. And I may add a risk
being crushed immediately by the
authorities if they create the
NGO outside of the state
structure. So fearing lies the
fundamental difference between
Western NGOs and their Chinese
counterpart, I want to take this
opportunity to point out another
level another set of difference
between Western civil society
and Chinese Civil Society, what
sense civil society came into
existence as a result of the
agitating growth of the social,
the Chinese Civil society could
only be born and flourished as a
result of the voluntary retreat
of the state home society. And
that retreat of the state from
society, of course, has been a
gradual and measured process.
There is no doubt that the gray
zones in China were much bigger
in size under the hooting Tao
region than under the current
region. However, I would say
there will always be a gray zone
for Chinese activists, you will
never disappear when a
politically sensitive issue
areas occur that may endanger an
NGO, the NGOs well and its
ability to negotiate with the
local state out of the out of
the dilemma is critical to its
survival. In the q&a, I would be
glad to share with you more
examples or more strategies of
how to cope with that the
sensors so bearing
nonconfrontational ethos in
mind, let's move on to the
examples of social media
activism staged Weibo. First, a
quick definition of social media
activism. It refers to social
actions triggered through peer
to peer networking between weak
ties and furthermore, those
social actions have mobilized
the viral communications to
create online support
communities at scale, so I
picked out five examples.
The first example is called a
shaved head action. In the mid
2000s Guangzhou based activists
Anil Hwei wrote a web blog,
calling for 1000 netizens fellow
netizens to shave their heads as
a symbolic gesture to stop the
city's night illumination
project on the program which
would cost the city taxpayers
more than 150 million yen
without much justification.
pamunkey posted his photos
before and after the shave, and
on Weibo, and in 20 hours, he
attracted 4000 retweets and
recruited more than 20 people to
follow him and shaved their
heads, including a young woman
and a few children. So what does
shading one's head have anything
to do with energy conservation?
Well, Anil Hwei argued mockingly
that 1000 shaved heads could
generate enough brightness to
light up the Pearl River and
render the level the leverage
city project unnecessary. So we
know that every joke is a tiny
revolution because it upsets the
established order. And polio
cheeky Weibo post went viral
precisely because protests
triggered by humor. Humor is an
is a potent form of non
confrontational ism. So protests
triggered by humor camouflage
the agitators and down funding
the censors. under the pressure
of public outcry and media
exposure, the city government
eventually trimmed down the
original the original budget of
night illumination by four
fifths, which is quite a victory
for Anil Hwei. My second example
deals with a thumbs up sister.
Now, when [?] was made his
protest against the city city's
native illumination project,
this young woman who dropped out
herself some subsystem that a
simultaneous protest against the
city government for is a lack of
transparency about the decision
making process that led to the
creation of such a wasteful
project. So in the name of
safeguarding public interest,
and in pursuit of governmental
accountability, she demanded
that the city government make
available a crucial document
that underwrote the night
illumination project, her
petition for a copy of that
document, hit the stone wall. It
was like they were passing the
buck from one office to the next
and never gave her a response.
So she was feeling very
frustrated. She then turned to
Weibo, to recruit 1000 netizens
willing to post their thumbs up
photos. Now thumbs up really is
a satirical play, signifying
just the opposite thumbs down.
While waiting for the the the
responding posts to trickle in.
This feisty young woman raised
the stakes by praying to special
presence gifts to the city to
the city hall to further
embarrass the authorities. What
did she bring, she brought jumbo
white pear. Now in Chinese, this
kind of pear is pronounced as
yali, which is homophonous to
another Chinese word, pressure,
Ámbar Reyes: yali.
Jing Wang: The under so she was
actually bringing the more
pressure to the city hall. The
other presence she brought to
the city officials. It was a
plastic ball shaped like a
porcupine, alluding to the
government's antics of passing
citizen petitions like hot
potatoes from court to court. So
hundreds of thumbs up photos
turned up under the hashtag
thumbs up sister, delivering the
facetious message to targeted
officials. The tactic that she
resorted to was meanwhile [?]
theming by fake pressing, which
is a form of indirect sanction.
familiar to the Chinese schooled
and the politics of sarcasm for
thousands of years. Other
playful Weibo fans understood
her strategy instantaneously. So
a small sensation was created
online. And not surprisingly,
this feisty young woman got
finally got a face to face
interview with the city
officials. My next example is a
LGBTQ example. When Iceland's
Prime Minister johannah and his
and her lesbian lover, were
paying a state visit to China.
This NGO supported for gay love
strategized ways of using social
media to promote social
acceptance of homosexuality. Now
during it after the state visit,
her wife was nowhere to be seen
in mainstream media because she
was removed predictably from all
media reports. So the NGO
founder spread the news through
a blog post, which saina.com the
host publisher featured on its
homepage for several days. And
you can imagine this blog was an
instantaneous attention grabber
with a click rate of more than
600 I'm sorry 800,000 times.
Within a few days it kicked off
a tongue in cheek campaign
slogan. Let's search for the
Prime Minister's harmonised
wife. Okay, so my next example
is free lunch for children,
which is a very famous Weibo
campaign. launched by some fake
piece of free agent, a
journalist, he discovered that
Guizhou province lacked contains
so he launched a crowdfunding
campaign on Weibo on free lunch
for children. He successfully
mobilized the millions, hundreds
of millions of Chinese netizens
to participate in the campaign
by donating one un. He then use
the funds raised to feed more
than 80,000 children per day, in
more than 300 schools spread
over central and western parts
of China. Now, most
significantly, the network
effect of that campaign forced
the Chinese government to
respond in kind. In 2012,
China's State Council rolled out
the policy which allocated 16
billion yen per year to improve
the nutrition of rural students.
By early 2015 32 million
children in 1300 counties have
benefited from the governmental
subsidy program. This case shows
how micro charity can actually
lead to successful advocacy. Why
I call this shadow advocacy
because neither Deng Fei nor his
Weibo supporters were
consciously engaged in policy
advocacy. Well, other people may
also say this is a case of wrong
hi Jen shoe human see military
tactics. The messaging goes like
this Chinese style okay. Beware
the crowd has spoken can the
government please pay attention?
Okay, so, my final example is an
environmental activism example.
The arrival of social media
platforms have made
environmental advocacy easier
and more efficient and faster.
Now, since 2009, there has been
a proliferating number of air
monitoring, soil monitoring
matter, water testing campaigns,
galvanizing citizen
participation. They exactly
example I wanted to share his
screen Pico, the NGO launched a
Pm 2.0 air monitoring campaign,
and they loaned portable air
monitors to local residents, who
then report who then reported
their testing results on Weibo.
Green Beagle also integrated a
crowdfunding campaign initiated
into the multi city advocacy
campaign. Simply put, their goal
was to mobilize 1000 donors per
city, requesting a minimum of 25
un per person to purchase air
monitoring equipments for each
city. Now Beijing, Shanghai,
Guangzhou and window have all
reached the goal. True to the
spirit of web 2.0, the original
Beijing based movement was
decentralized and and the spread
over into multiple local
campaigns with another sense all
over China responding to the
call by setting up their own
city named Weibo hashtag, for
example, will have Pm 2.0 to 2.5
error monitoring, or Shanghai Pm
2.5. They are monitoring and so
on. So all those campaigns were
created with the purpose of
bringing incremental change. By
now it should be obvious that
there are many activists in
China and they are making social
change in measured non
contentious and measured steps.
scholars in China and the other
parts of the world have been
debating over the vice and
virtue of scatter slacktivism or
fingertip philanthropy. Those
turns out the rogatory
descriptions of casual random
acts such as taking a snapshot
of polluted river or sending a
virtual leaf to create a virtual
tree as opposed to engaging in
sustained environmental activism
and longer term systemic
operations of actions on the
ground as an activist myself A
practitioner of both online and
offline activism. I support the
argument that Twitter and other
social media platforms have
enabled activists to create new
communities and spread their
social courses to a wider
public. I also believe that
small acts can add up and can
trigger qualitative change over
time. So why do activists have
to choose between online and
offline action? And why do we as
researchers have to arbitrate
which which form is superior to
the other? While we have another
saying that runs parallel to all
roads lead to Rome, the same
goes all rivers find their ways
to the ocean. So the ocean of
compassion does not discriminate
against small streams or drops
of dew. Okay, now we come to the
final topic on my menu, future
village, which is designed for
good project that I launched
last summer in China.
We all knew about smart city
paradigms, right, which is a top
down investment driven and
governmental sponsored project
that gives a digital facelift to
big cities. NGO 2.0 is
interested in helping out
villages, not cities, we are
committed to energizing
grassroots network and reviving
grassroots culture and we are
naturally drawn to methods
filled down grassroots
mobilization. In a nutshell, the
future they're just driven by
three horses, designed for good
tech for good and poverty
alleviation. The future program,
the future village program was
inspired by the MIT Fab Lab
model. As some of you may know,
the Fab Lab model emphasizes the
making of open source hardware
and collaborative design with
the clientele and in this case,
our clientele or the villages.
The fackler model demonstrates
how an underserved community can
be powered by technology and
other means at the grassroots
level. So how do we go about
this program? After we identify
a future village candidate, we
first asked the villages to
identify and to articulate a
collected need. We then mobilize
researchers and practitioners
from different sectors to run a
civic to run the Civic hackathon
as the first step. And I
emphasize this is the first step
of building trust and the
working relationship with the
villages. Here is a working
definition of this first step of
the future village. Through
hackathons. We bring together
makers and tacky software
developers, researchers from
material science, architecture,
bio ecology, design thinking
public art, art, practitioners
and more. And the participants
include the villagers,
university teachers and
students, high school students,
programmers, designers,
engineers, artists, etc. and
jointly, we design vision for
future village. We have
implemented this program in four
villages. So here I want to
share with you one village. This
is a village in the Curtin
desert in North China, and
environmental NGO, they're
contacted us. Now in China. The
most conventional way of
greening The desert is to drop
the seed bombs into the desert,
and then leave the siblings
there to survive by themselves,
which, as you can imagine, is
not a very effective method of
greening the desert. So this
NGO, instead of planting trees
in the desert, they hand in a
sandy area and build a fence
around it to ward off intruding
animals, including humans, to
let the land recover by itself.
Their experiment was very
successful, as you can tell by
looking at the satellite image,
they just see the square square
that has turned green. That was
their first experiment. But very
few people knew about what they
were doing. So they came to us
they came to NGO 2.0 with a
communication need. They wanted
more people to know about their
unique method of greening the
desert. So we ran a hackathon
for them. We, the hackathon
produced four solutions. Then
I'm going to share three
solutions with you. The first
solution, the first one team
resorted to the concept of Earth
art. By working with artists to
design Earth shapes that look
cool. We know that interesting
Earth art is communication
intensive by itself. So it would
create a very cool satellite
image better than that square
result. That's powerful
communication. The second
solution is a son project. We're
working with music artists, to
design ways of collecting sand
in the in the in the windy
desert, each season would create
yield different sense, we then
treat the sound and sell the
sound bites as ringtones to help
the NGO raise funds and to also
raise public awareness of the
village. And our third solution
is a WeChat game.
The game starts with a green, a
piece of Greenland, and the
player has to eject animals and
humans that were dropped from
above onto the Greenland. And if
the ejection is successful, then
the green expanse if it fails,
and the green shrinks. Alright,
so those are the solutions that
came out of the hackathon. So
what about the next steps? Well,
after the hackathon is done, we
then enter the village with
experts, high school students,
university students. at regular
intervals, are we engaging on
site conversation with villagers
and the village leadership to
explore other needs that could
be tackled by our team. And the
goal of those regular visits is
to explore the possibilities of
helping villagers to discover
new forces of production,
improve their environment, their
livelihood, and also enrich the
cultural life of village
children. Most of them were left
behind children, because their
parents usually go to big cities
to to work to make their ends to
make a living. So the cultural
life of village children would
like to enrich the cultural life
of village children through a
variety of measures, some of
which would involve media and
technology and technology. But
not everything we do is
technological, because we also
involve other other people,
public art practitioners in the
program, for example. This is a
quick bird's eye view of our
collaborators on the future
village program. You can tell by
that there are three
universities to IT companies or
museum and tacky communities.
I'm sharing the future village
program with you for a purpose I
wanted to illustrate how NGO 2.0
operates. Building multi
sectoral collaboration is our
DNA. We work with different
sectors to produce social good.
And the sectors include not only
the NGO sector, but also the
universities, IT companies,
design companies, packy
communities and so on. I should
call all those social actors,
nonconfrontational change
makers. And together, we are
building a decentralized multi
sectoral coalition that is
purposeful, but non contentious,
driven by a powerful and spoken
consensus of all the parties
involved to build a better
society. This is the end of my
presentation.
And I welcome comments and
questions. Thank you.
Vivek Bald: Um, so, if you don't
mind, I'm, I have a question
that I wanted.
in some ways, you know, you
could say that that is, is
confrontational, but it's, it's
not, right.
And, and, but there, you know,
that young woman, you know, must
have felt
like the, the,
the that the risks were not as
Hi, as
you know that that there was
enough that she would have
enough of a response, a popular
response, so that whatever risks
involved might have been
minimized. Right.
And I so I guess my question, I
have a couple of questions that
branch off from that example.
And that is,
one, you know, what, in, in
terms of your own understanding
or definition of what counts as
confrontational? What is not
what is non confrontational?
Okay. No, is that based upon
just the western ideas of that
you're pushing back against of
sort of direct on, you know,
boots on the ground action? And
then just quickly, the second
part of that is,
you know, have you seen examples
where,
where the, where individuals or
NGOs have engaged in what might
have felt like or seemed like,
non confrontational activism in
the way that you're describing
it? But the state saw that as
crossing a certain line? back?
Jing Wang: Yeah, sure. This is a
very good question, because it
allows me to talk about several
things that I didn't have time
to address my talk. First of
all, the the thumbs up sister
and the guy who shaved his head,
he lives in Guangzhou. Now,
locale is very important. China
is not a homogenous entity.
Guangzhou is known to be one of
the most liberal, one of the
most open minded and the liberal
city, in China. And also okay.
So here I can I can share with
you our experience in the in
2010, and 2011. We did. We did
two, literacy, so social media
literacy training workshops, one
evening nine and one in unquie.
And we, we had a very bad time,
because we were pursued by
public security officers in
those provinces. So this is
something fascinating about
China, because it the world,
every locale, has a different
definition of what is tolerable.
What is tolerable? What is, what
is the boundary, right? Every
locale sort of, is semi
autonomous in deciding on what
is allowed to take place within
my province. So after 2010,
after those two bad experiences,
I made a decision in 2011, to
hold a workshop in Beijing,
right under the nose of the
Emperor. And I, my logic went
that if they didn't, if the
center, if the central
government didn't like what I'm
doing, then just shut me down. I
wouldn't, I don't want to play
the Catan and, and, and mice
game with the local with the
local governments. So this is
one thing I've gone through is
fairly liberal, that allowed
them to do what they did. I
don't think what they did will
be tolerated in England, for
example, or in Beijing. The
other thing I wanted to point
out is that the guidelines for
censorship is not what we
thought, in the West. The
Chinese censors do not
necessarily disallow individual
dissent, what they care about is
to prevent individual dissent
from escalating into a
collective action against the
government. So to a to a certain
extent, individual dissent is
allowed. It is because of the
discrepancies of locale, it
allows activists to navigate. So
if I couldn't do something
Beijing I I can do it in in
Jiangsu province or other
places.
Unknown: Thanks. Yes.
Ámbar Reyes: Hi. And thank you
so much for your stuff. I was
wondering what themes or cases
have you noticed that get more
like positive responses in
activism, and also how to cope
with the I get like pro
government but who made want to
upset catalyze the collective
action online? Like, yeah,
Jing Wang: I didn't get the
second part of
Ámbar Reyes: like, how to cope
with the government but online
got out of the box, but like
yeah, like b-o-t-s
Unknown: offs,
Ámbar Reyes: like the fake
profiles that might want to like
prohibit you know, like these
like actions online.
Jing Wang: Okay. All right. Um,
first question What kinds of NGO
issue areas that are more
acceptable right to the to the
government? Well, many Chinese
NGOs create state sanctioned
nonprofit programs, for example,
providing educational assistance
to children living in poor
families, in poor families in
rural and urban China, or
providing social welfare to the
elderly and the, the other
friend disfranchise scopes and
so on. I didn't quite understand
the second question. So, could
somebody maybe help
me phrasing the question Emily,
Eric Gordon: I another word, I
think you might be reaching for
umbar is moderators like how do
moderators work on online forums
to censor what people say? Oh,
Jing Wang: they they have a list
of taboos terms and concepts.
Internally, they every social
media platform has hired those
officers to monitor the posts,
so they have a list
is that
and I learned
Ámbar Reyes: but how, how an
activist could like try to go
their own like campaign without,
you know, like, getting like
censored. Okay. Oh, yeah, sure.
Jing Wang: Okay. They are
different strategies. Okay.
Yeah, a different strategy. So,
one strategy is to, to, to make
incremental change, which is
crucial, you know, measured step
by step change agenda,
alleviates the anxieties of the
state. So that's rules of the
thumb. First, one second, it has
to do how you position yourself,
for example, into 2.0, I could
have positioned into 2.0 as a
media focused NGO, but media is
too sensitive. So instead, I
position ourselves as a
technology driven NGO, I very
rarely use the word media in
China. The other strategy would
be resorting to the to the
tactics of camouflage, study,
strategic hiding, or systemic
mimicry aimed at facing one some
presence from the photographic
media of surveillance. And there
are many examples of, of, of
camouflage. The other very, very
popular method of coping with
censors is to resort to the
rhetoric of the powerful to curb
the exercise of power. What I
meant is legitimize legitimizing
and framing your contention by
employing state laws, official
policy, discourse, state
propaganda, governmental
commitments to hamstring
concerned party elites for
support and for collaboration.
In more concrete terms, so let
me give you an example about
organizations run by Tibetans
and Muslims in China. They
typically framed their mission
as cultural perseverance rather
than the promotion of religious
diversity. And take NGR take HIV
AIDS organizations, they
typically frame resort to public
health approach rather than
dwelling on the issues of human
rights. So there are many, many
ways to work around the
obstacles. But incremental ism
is what everybody sort of. Yeah.
resorts to. I'm very happy that
I am in the US. Because that
sort of prevented us from making
jumps and leaps in our
activities, which is good for
us. The other thing, the other
thing is that one has to have a
low profile. So for the first
five years, during the NGO 2.0,
while I was running into a
compiler, I rejected all
interviews by media. Because we
were too weak at that time at
the beginning, and I didn't want
to be identified. So it was not
until after 2014, after we were
officially registered as an NPO,
that I began to talk to
journalists in China. I
Vivek Bald: think both Eric and
Diego had Hands up.
But I didn't see who raised
their hands first.
Diego Cerna Aragon: I guess I
guess I can go.
Thank you. For high for your
presentation. I really love the
reference to James Scott's work,
I think was really good. So I
have a question, probably
related to Professor bolt
question about like Northwestern
and Western, this kind of like
differentiation. I was thinking
about the dissociation, because
there is also some times where
actions that that seek social
change in our Western context, a
confrontational stance, right?
Especially like, in the
countries of Latin America,
probably not in China, right.
There are sometimes like other
[?] or friends that occupy
certain terrains in some of the
bigger shores build a, a shanty
town, because they are fighting
for housing rights. And this
obviously breaks the rule of
law, right, as we understand
that in like, kind of, like
Western city context, right. So
I know your work is focused on
China specifically, but I guess
my my, my question would be, how
if we can think about like,
activism from a global
perspective, taking not into
account so much binary between
no Western Western perspective,
but more like a gradient or a
more nuanced view of what is
like actually confrontational
approach rolling also
conditional strategies. This
Yeah. Oh,
Jing Wang: do you mind
rephrasing your question?
Diego Cerna Aragon: Yeah, I
think if we can, like so prolly
surpass binaries, conceptions,
binary concepts of activism
between Western Western and
think more about probably a
nuanced view of like, probably
something is more
confrontational at other and not
so much assignment.
Or confrontational?
Jing Wang: Yeah, it is. Well, as
I said earlier, there is a
continuum of situations. So
there are different great
different shades of grey, right.
So I, I, I actually don't know
how to
how to respond to your question,
except that
that,
that there that it is what the
gray zones is really, really, I
think big, right? Even though it
varies from region to region,
but but it is there. And one,
you know, I think one has to our
as an activist, you always try
to walk the fine line between or
in authoritarians countries, you
walk a fine line between
compliance and self empowerment,
which is not intuitive exercise.
So yeah, well, well, in China
now, it's quite impossible to
openly challenge the Chinese
government and I think Hong
Kong, the Hong Kong protests,
services, a good example
that well, that
The Hong Kong situation, I think
a cause for a total of a an
entirely different response than
what I talked about. Yeah. What
What do you think? I mean, what?
Since since I'm not sure I
completely understood your
question, and I would like to
get a sense of how you approach
your own question.
Diego Cerna Aragon: So I guess
there is like,
there are, there are not
necessarily a correspondence
between like non confrontational
and non Western activism, but
probably not in a Western
context, you can have
confrontational extra days. And
so I, I guess, I, I tried to
complicate the issue of like,
not necessarily approaching
certain contexts with a certain
framing of how activists should
be in this context.
Jing Wang: Well, you know, non
confrontational ism is just a, a
term that incorporates all kinds
of approaches. Right. Um,
Vivek Bald: um, Eric, would you
like to go next? And then it
looks like Tomás, and then
Emily.
Eric Gordon: Great, thanks. And
thanks for the really
interesting talk. I have a
number of questions, but I'm
gonna keep it to one. I'm
specifically interested in what
you talked about that kind of
multi sectoral collaboration
that you talked about at the
end. And, and my question comes
from work that I'm actually
doing in Eastern Europe around
the same, this the same concept
and trying to understand ways in
which multiple, you know, groups
from multiple sectors can
effectively collaborate towards
common cause. In in, in, in
Eastern European context, there
is government involved, I
imagine that in, in the Chinese
context, government is not one
of the sectors that is that is
involved. But what I'm
interested in is, and I know the
difficulty in this work is
aligning the incentives of the
different the different players.
And I'm curious if you could
talk a little bit about how sure
how you've how you've addressed
that how you work to align those
incentives to achieve your
goals.
Jing Wang: All right. Thank you,
Eric. First of all, I want to
say that MIT is a powerful brand
name, which allowed me to really
quickly round up collaborators.
It took me like a couple of
months to set up into 2.0 in
2008. And I think Asian people,
including the Chinese are,
really worship their university
like my MIT. I remember one son
riding in a taxi in Beijing, and
got into a conversation with the
taxi cab driver. And he asked
me, he, he knew that I was not
local paper. So I just didn't
look like a local painting. So I
told him that I'm a professor.
And he said, Oh, yeah, he
thought his Chinese professor,
but then I said, MIT, he went
like, Oh, my God, MIT. Can I
have a photo with you? So that
kind of positive. Very response
to MIT. So the brand name helped
a great deal. The MIT brand name
helped me round up, techies. And
the universities. It is
effortless for me to set up. To
set up collaborative ties with
Chinese universities. I think,
always the challenges is easier
to invite collaborators, but
it's difficult to let them go.
So now I'm getting very cautious
about inviting people to join
incentives. And the those
people, okay, the social sector
in China is a rather small
sector. Everybody knew each
other sort of, so if you
identified one, collaborator,
they you will be led to the
others. We work with it
corporations, we really don't
work with the IT companies
themselves. We work with the
volunteers within the IT
company. They are techies. They
are programmers. So they're
hardware makers. So I guess
well, did I did I? Did I answer
some of your questions? Or do
you want to sort of keep keep
keep asking if I didn't give you
a? a full answer?
Eric Gordon: Well, I can follow
up with you later. I know, we're
almost out of time. So I'll let
other people.
Jing Wang: Other questions. All
right. Thank you.
Vivek Bald: Tomás.
Tomás Guarna: Good. So I'm
interested in the in the role of
funding. So I know that a very
common to illiberal regimes used
to constrain the role of NGOs is
to not allow them to receive
external funding or to Yeah, to
find a way to indirectly
restrain them in that sense. And
I was wondering, um, yeah, in
your work, how has this resulted
in, in bringing funding probably
from the US, right? And how do
Chinese NGOs work with that?
Jing Wang: Okay, so funding,
kept me, kept me awake at night.
Actually, since I started NGO,
2.0, my insomnia got worse, I
have to pay for my employees.
Right? We were funded by for the
beginning. for 10 years,
actually, they continue to fund
us. And because of their
funding, we were sort of suspect
right in the eyes of the public
security officers and also in
the eyes of other collaborators.
Before we got registered in
2014, it was difficult for us to
really attract funding in China.
But I do not want to get more
funding from the US because they
would make us look even more
dangerous, right?
So
I was able to, again, use my MIT
the logo, MIT logo, to attract
funding from, from companies
like a financial company,
actually, they funded us to
develop our crowdsource
philanthropy map. We My goal is
to diversify our funding so that
we will not be left in the code
if one founder walked away. For
time, we had a very difficult
year in 2008, because the
Chinese government clamped down
on foreign NGOs, meaning Ford
Foundation was monitored. And
they are for the whole year, I
would not have any funding. And
it was a very difficult year.
But now things got better fourth
Foundation, I think, past the
past another hurdle, and they
are fine. They are under the
jurisdiction of the US China
friendship Association. And they
continue to fund us, but they
are not the only funder, so we
are in a better situation. Did I
answer your question, Tomás?
Tomás Guarna: perfectly. Thank
you.
Jing Wang: You're welcome.
Vivek Bald: Emily, and then we
have a question from the
attendee q&a after Emily. Sure.
Emily Grandjean: Thank you very
much for speaking to us today. I
have a question about the people
who are leading these movements
to create incremental in
writing. Like the woman whose
photo you showed who brought
that pair to the like city, and
then the young man who shaved
his head. And I'm wondering
whether there's a certain
threshold beyond which if they
lead to many movements, they
become kind of a person of
interest, and can't really
continue to try to create change
in different ways. And then also
how that varies by by region,
I'm imagining it might, based on
what you were talking about
earlier, and then also by their
Eric Gordon: kind of,
like level of awareness or level
of, like high profile, high
profile illness, like if you
are, you know, at, for example,
your level versus someone who's
just a young person in a in a
city, whether your relative sort
of command of power might affect
your ability to continue to
create incremental incremental
change across different
movements. And sorry, that was
really convoluted. Let me know
if I should.
Jing Wang: I will, I will adjust
your question. If I if I didn't
give you a satisfactory answer.
You can always follow up with
another question. So yeah, I
would imagine that that the
thumbs up sister will not do
another way boy campaign,
because then that she would be
inviting the spotlight, which is
not good. That explains why I
have stayed low. I had I have
kept a low profile until 2015.
Because I do not want to
incremental ism is about
anonymous tea. So why are you
going to Why? Why do you want to
attract the media attention to
you? In Chinese we have another
saying a pig is afraid of being
fat, because that would be the
time for the for the pig to be
slaughtered. So so so that,
yeah, you you're supposed to
keep a low profile. And I don't
think she will keep protesting,
or at another occasion, it would
be very dangerous. But Amina
wakey. He, he has been working
with an NGO in Guangzhou all the
time. So he is fine. One or the
other. I think you probably
brought up another question, but
I think I lost my focus. I knew
that was very helpful. Yeah.
Now, did you have another
question that I haven't
addressed? I think you you
covered it. Thank you. All
right. Great. Thank you.
Vivek Bald: Well, I have a
question from hamidreza. In the
QA, who asks, or about culture,
specifically?
And
here's the question, I was
wondering about non
confrontational activism in the
art scene, especially in
underground spaces, music,
cinema, literature, etc. Two
things, one, their modes of
production and distribution. And
second, how does your argument
regarding the paradox of
invisibility under the light
hold for that scene? Do you find
ground?
Jing Wang: Do you mind pasting
that question onto the chat box?
Sure. I can look at it.
Unknown: Second,
Jing Wang: Oh, q&a.
Vivek Bald: Well, you may be
able to see it actually.
Unknown: Oh, here we go. Okay.
All right. Man, I'm in the art
Jing Wang: spaces
nonconfrontational in the heart
sing.
Um,
in the art scene, which is say
that the, the earth art example,
I think that that is an example
of, of non confrontational
activism. And how this? Well,
you see, the thing about non
confrontational this of is that
you shouldn't be afraid of being
exposed, because it is non
confrontation.
Does that make sense?
Vivek Bald: Is let me Why don't
I follow up on that a little
bit? And that is there? Yeah. Is
there a vibrant kind of
underground music scene, for
example, where, both in terms of
lyrically and in terms of the
kind of spaces that the young
people are building? You know,
do those also become spaces that
are under this rubric of non
confrontational action.
Jing Wang: Well, listen, the
album, the company, the music
company will not will not
release a song or an album, that
is considered problematic. So
and also, you know, I think, in
China is not just the censorship
imposed on practitioners, but
internal censorship. you
internalize the internalize, as
a citizen, you internalize
things that you think might
create a stir or invite the the
unnecessary attention from the
public, from the state or from
the public. So I would I would
say,
China relies more on
those kinds of internal
censorship, inner policing,
inner policing. Then external
censorship. But to answer your
question quickly, no art new
music that is made public will
be will be problematic because
they're already filtered. There
is already a filtering system
that is going out the the the
the, the so called dangerous or
politically incorrect messaging.
But there's one thing that I
think you all need to know is
that the censors are not like,
they're not like devils, they,
they communicate with, you know,
if they spot something
problematic like with us we were
approached by by sensors
sometimes you know, they didn't
understand why we were doing
this. So they came to us they
said, Can we have a
conversation? You know, I have a
question about this. So you
explain it to them. And that
example I had was years ago, I
had an article published, I
wanted to seek a publisher in,
in China. And eventually I got
that piece published in Beijing,
not in Shanghai, contrary to
your intuitive perception,
Beijing is a is a place that has
more free room to for us to
navigate then Shanghai, because
there are two governments in
Beijing, there is a central
government there is the
municipal government. So you if
you, if you lost the favor with
one with the Father, you could
go to your grandfather, and you
get your things done. So I got
article had a few words that
sort of hit the button, hit the
hit the flag. So I got an email
one day from the publisher
saying, hey, Professor Wong,
this article is great. We'd like
to publish it. But there are a
few words, I wonder if you would
consider revising what you would
consider replacing. So to my big
surprise, one word that they
singled out was capitalism. It's
like, What on earth, you know,
capitalism. So I replaced that
word with the commodity economy.
So they communicated with you.
If an NGO is in trouble, you
will get a call from the local
government and the, the ufan the
euphemism is you will be invited
out to have tea. You're invited
out of tea, meaning the sensor
wants to talk to you. So you sit
down, you sorted things out, and
you make some adjustment.
Communication dialogues is
crucial for NGOs to operate
smoothly. Something that the
Hong Kong protesters didn't do
or didn't want to do, which was
really sad.
Vivek Bald: Okay, okay. I think
we're just coming up on 630. So,
just wanted to thank you
sincerely, for for this really
rich talk and discussion. And
thank all of you who attended